and invasive species in the Florida
Everglades is threatening the area's
sprawling ecosystem Burmese pythons are
our four apex predators at the top of
the food chain South Florida has hired
25 top hunters to capture and kill the
snakes and nearly 17 footlong Python was
killed last week now it is the longest
captured so far in this program
mark Strassmann has a first-hand look at
how the snake hunters are going
high-tech
in a remote corner of the Florida
Everglades we found Rodney Irwin hunting
by drone for a snake in the grass on an
embankment 20 yards away the drone
spotted this 7-foot Burmese python
warming itself on a rock
Irwin closed in this is a Burmese python
and this is the one that's causing all
the trouble
Burmese pythons giant constrictors
native to Asia became a nuisance in
Florida after 1992 Hurricane Andrew
toppled a reptile breeding facility and
all its pythons slithered into the wild
female Burmese can lay dozens of eggs at
a time and by one estimate 100,000
Burmese live in the Everglades
today some can grow longer than 20 feet
and here this invasive species has no
natural predators they're non-venomous
but those rows of teeth are razor sharp
the Burmese coils itself around its prey
squeezes and suffocates it before
swallowing whole this video shot late
last year in the Everglades shows a
Burmese strangling an alligator there
have a articulating jaw and that allows
them to be able to eat and swallow just
massive objects that you would not think
that a snake could do they captured one
here not too far from here that had a
deer inside to these muscular eating
machines the Everglades are like a
buffet that never close
they devour birds and mammals and
disrupt food sources for Panthers
alligators and other creatures this
month the South Florida Water Management
District launched a Burmese bounty
program through May 25 elite hunters
like Erlin can capture and kill as many
as possible they also get to sell what
they catch I make a whopping eight
dollars and 15 cents an hour and when
you capture a snake anything under four
feet is $50 and then it's $25 a foot as
it goes up hunters have trapped roughly
100 snakes already some of them huge
Patrick Campbell's catch measured 15
feet 10 inches
Leo Sanchez and Nicolas Bono's nabbed
this 15 footer
it weighed 144 pounds we saw up close
the 1 Sanchez and Banyas caught dead but
still intimidating outside Brian Woods
exotic leather store in Hollywood
Florida these are my large selection of
alligator would has spent nearly 30
years selling animal skins to marquee
names like gucci and ur mays so your
view capture these things bringing them
to you good for the environment good for
business
absolutely it's good for the environment
it's good for the hunters and it's good
for everyone so it's a win-win that's
not a lot of money I don't do this for
the money Rodney Owens sees himself as
fighting on the frontlines of South
Florida's war on the Burmese I do this
because it needs to be done in hunters
like him this opportunistic predator may
finally have met its match for CBS this
morning
mark Strassmann Miami Wow that they got
job openings